Messi Te estamos esperando era el
mensaje que se leía frente a un
supermercado de la familia de Antonela
roccuzzo la esposa del futbolista
argentino Lionel Messi el local ubicado
en la ciudad de Rosario fue alcanzado
por 14 balas disparadas por dos hombres
armados que se movilizaban en una
motocicleta el hecho fue condenado por
el propio presidente argentino Alberto
Fernández hoy amanecí
con una noticia fea en Rosario donde
habían baleado un supermercado
me comuniqué enseguida con el intendente
hablé enseguida con el jefe de gabinete
le dije pongámonos en marcha ya para ver
algo además habrá que hacer estamos
haciendo mucho pero evidentemente algo
más habrá que hacer lo que los que
tienen armas la nota también hacía
referencia al alcalde de la ciudad Pablo
quien catalogaban de narcotraficante El
funcionario culpó a las fuerzas de
seguridad por no combatir de manera
efectiva el crimen organizado unas
declaraciones que fueron contestadas por
el ministro de seguridad Aníbal
Fernández y si yo le digo que hace 20
años que están en esta situación Usted
cree que no han ganado han ganado Ahora
hay que revertirla nosotros estamos
dispuestos a revertirla Sí nosotros
Nosotros sí Seguro que sí Rosario en
donde nació Lionel Messi y dio sus
primeros golpes a la pelota es la
tercera ciudad más grande de Argentina
una que en los últimos años se ha visto
azotada por el narcotráfico y que ha
visto aumentar sus índices de violencia
la urbe presentó más de 280 homicidios
en 2022 una cifras que no tiene ninguna
otra ciudad del país